welcome everyone to an another topic on
ci cd pipeline using jenkins
now in this one we are going to talk
about that how exactly we can go for
a csid implementation with a pipeline
concept
and that too with the help of jenkins
tool so let's talk about what exactly
we're going to talk about
now uh first of all we are going to talk
about like what exactly is in devops
process
and then we are going to talk about what
is the importance of ci cd pipeline
uh then we are going to take care of a
kind of a sample pipeline which is there
a kind of a building a ci cd pipeline
with the help of jenkins here and then
in the end we are going to see a small
demo
on how we can do this setup so that we
can have some particular pipeline
processed
and executed and processed all together
so let's talk about the different things
one by one
now the first one is that what exactly
is in devops here
now devops is basically a combination of
two practices
like that is the development and
operations so development is having
their own task of doing the development
and preparing the source code and
operation is responsible for
deploying the source code to a specific
environment whether it's a production
or any you know other environment so
they take care of all those tasks
creating the virtual machines managing
performing the patching and number of
tasks there from the
operations perspective now development
is
something which keeps on working on the
source code there on the development and
they
are responsible for keeping a particular
uh product
up and running so they um do the
performance they
you know they do the coding they do the
uh particular interaction with the
testing to you know validate their
source code
a huge number of activities is actually
done by the development team
and they eventually use an end number of
tools like scripting tools
coding tools development tools lot of
tools they basically use
to support their development because
they are performing different kind of
programming they
it could be a possibility that more than
one programming language
is being used for your project so that's
kind of
you know wider scope is present as such
over here when we talk about the
devops here now from the operations
perspective
uh it's basically a team which is
responsible for managing the
workforce right and it's something which
we can use to
see that all the daily uh activities and
operations
should be managed effectively and
efficient so that's the main
important uh point over here that
whenever we are working with the
operations whenever we are working on
that we should be able to get a kind of
a decent amount of work and decent
amount of activities
managed with the help of operations
teams here so operation teams
is pretty much responsible for keeping
the environment up and running
and whatever the activities and
maintenance work we want to do
we will be able to do on that
now devops really helps us to achieve a
lot of
milestones over here now let's talk
about that one by one
so very first one of that is that it
helps us to get a frequent release of
deliveries here
now we were doing the releases prior to
devops also but that was not that much
frequent
probably people were doing like every
quarter every three months four months
that kind of
time duration was being used by the team
to uh deliver the source code or deliver
into a specific
environment but the moment the uh
specific
devops comes into the picture the
frequency of this release
uh really increased a lot so some
organization in fact
uh trying to do like every month release
twice a month so
that's the kind of frequency which we
are getting when we move on to the
devops
so that really helped and you know got
efficient with the introduction of
devops here
now second one is the team collaboration
now that is also improved drastically
because earlier
the operations and the development teams
were not working in that collaboration
they were like working involved in their
own task but with the help of devops
they really come along and you know had
a very good
team collaborations which really helps
them to increase the overall
productivity
and the performance of the product so
these are the prime
milestones which we achieve with the
implementation of devops
as such into a project another one is
that it helps to
get a kind of a management a better
management here so
effective and efficient management is
what we get with the help of devops
because ultimately you have redefined
your processes
you have implemented certain development
tools certain automations
and that really helps you to increase
the overall management of
all your unplanned work so the planning
is something which got really improved
with the help of
devops and faster resolution of issues
because
the way you are delivering your uh
source code to the production
environment
you are pretty much doing it into a less
duration of time and when that is
happening
definitely there is an kind of a
increase
in the number of bugs which is getting a
result and
there is another benefit that you know
ultimately the number of bugs which you
are getting in production
that drastically reduced in case of
devops
so since we are getting less number of
issues than bugs it's very easy for us
to do
the resolutions quite quickly and
implement into a specific production
environment
right so devops today is being
implemented by
you know most of the major organizations
whether it's a financial organization
whether it's a kind of a service
organization
every organization is somehow looking
forward for the implementation and the
adaptation
of devops because it totally redefines
and automate the whole development
process all together
and whatever the manual efforts you were
putting earlier that is simply or gets
automated with the help of these tools
here
so this is something which get really
implemented because
of some of the important uh feature like
a ci cd pipeline because
cacd pipeline is responsible for
delivering your source code into the
production environment in large duration
of time
so cicd pipeline is ultimately the goal
which
really helps us to deliver more into the
production environment when we talk
about from
this perspective now let's talk about
that what exactly is a cacd pipeline now
when we go into that part
when we go into that understanding so
cicd pipeline is
a basically continuous integration and
continuous delivery concept
which is used or which is considered as
a backbone of the overall devops
approach
now it's one of the prime approach which
we
implement when we are going for a devops
implementation for our project
so if i have to go for a devops
implementation the very first and the
minimum implementation
and the automation which i'm looking
forward is actually from the
uh particular ci cd pipelines here so
cicd pipelines
is really a wonderful option when we
talk about the devops here
so what exactly is the pipeline term all
about so
pipeline is in series of events that are
connected together with each other it's
kind of a sequence of
the various steps like you know
typically when we talk about any kind of
deployment
so we have like you know build process
like we compile the source code
which enter the artifacts we do the
testing and then we deploy to a specific
environment
all these various steps which we use to
do it like manually
that is something which we can do it
into a pipeline so pipeline is nothing
but a sequence of
all these steps interconnected with each
other executed one by one
into a particular sequence now the
pipelines is responsible for performing
a variety of tasks
like building up the source code running
the test cases
uh probably the deployment can also be
added up in when we go for
the uh continuous integration and
continuous delivery there
so all these steps are being done into a
sequence definitely because
sequence is very important when we talk
about the pipeline so
you need to talk about the sequence the
same way in which you are working on the
development
and in a typical world the same thing
you will be putting up into a specific
pipeline so that's a very important
aspect to be considered now let's talk
about what is the continuous integration
here
now continuous integration is also you
know known as the ci
uh pretty much you can see that a lot of
tools are actually
named as ci but they are referring to
the continuous integration only
so continuous integration is a practice
that integrates
the source code into a shared repository
and
it used to automate the verification of
the source code so
it involves the build automations test
cases automation so
it also helps us to detect the issues
and the bugs
quite easily and quite faster that's a
very early mechanism which we can do as
such if we want to resolve
all these problems now continuous
integrations
does not eliminate the bugs but yes it
definitely helps them
uh you know easily to find out because
we we are talking about the uh
automated process we are talking about
the automated test cases
so definitely that is something which
can help us
to uh find out the bugs and then you
know the development can
help on that and they can you know
proceed with those bugs and they can try
to resolve
those things one by one so it's not a
kind of automated process which will
eventually remove the bugs bugs is
something which you have to recode and
you have to fix it
by following the development practice
but yes it can really help us to find
those bugs
quite easy and help them to remove
now what is the continuous delivery here
so continuous delivery also known as cd
is in kind of a phase in which the
changes are made uh
into the code before the deployment now
in this case what happens that uh
it's um something which we are
discussing or we are validating that
what exactly we want to deliver it to
the customer so
what exactly we are going ahead or we
are moving to the customer so that's
what
we typically do in case of continuous
delivery
and the ultimate goal of the pipeline is
to make the deployments
that's the end result because coding is
not the only thing
you code the programs you do the
development after that it's all about
the
deployments like how you're going to
that to perform the deployment so that
is a very important aspect
you want to go ahead with the
deployments that's right you can go
there and that's a real beauty about
this because
it's in kind of a way in which we can
identify
that how the deployments can be run or
can be executed as such here
right so the ultimate goal for the
pipeline is nothing but to do the
deployments
and to proceed further on that right
so when both these practices are placed
in together in an order so all these
steps could be referred as in complete
automated process
and this process is known as cicd so
when we are talking about like when we
are working on this automation
so in that case what happens that we are
looking forward that how the automation
needs to be done
and since it's in kind of a ci cd
automation which we are talking about
so it's nothing but the uh end result
would be like build and deployment
automation
so you will be taking care of both the
build and the test case executions and
the deployments as such
when we talk about as such the cacd here
the implementation of chcd also enables
the team to do the build and deploys
quite quickly
and uh efficiently because these are
things which is you know happening
automatically so there is no manual
efforts involved and there is no scope
of human error also
so we have frequently seen that while
doing the deployments we may miss some
binaries or some miss can be there so
that is something which is you know
completely removed as such when we talk
about this
the process makes the teams more agile
productive and the
uh confident here because um the
automations definitely gives a kind of a
boost to the confidence
that yes things are going to work
perfectly fine and there is no issues as
such
present now why exactly jenkins like
jenkins is what we
typically understand or we you know uh
here and there that it's in ci2
it's a cd tool so what exactly is
jenkins all about so jenkins is also
known as
a kind of orchestration tool it's an
automated tool which is there
and the best part is that it's
completely open source yes there are
some
particular or paid or the enterprise
tools are there like cloud b's and all
but there is no as such of offering
difference between the cloudbees
and the jenkins here so jenkins is a
kind of open source tool
which a lot of organizations pretty much
implement as it is itself
so even if they don't want to go um we
have seen in a lot of
big organizations where you know they
are not going for the enterprise tool
like cloud b's and all
and they are going for the pretty much
you know core jenkins software
as such here so this tool uh makes it
easy for the developers
to integrate the changes to the project
that is something which is very
important because
it can really help the teams to say that
how the things can be done and how it
can be performed over there
so the tools is really easy for the
developers to integrate
and that's the biggest uh you know
benefit which we are getting when we
talk about these
tools as such so jenkins is a really
important tool to be considered when we
talk about all these
automations now jenkins achieves
continuous integration with the help of
plugins
that is also a kind of another feature
or benefit which we get
because there are so many plugins which
is available there as such
which is being used and uh for example
you want to have an integration with
kubernetes
docker and all maybe by default those
plugins are not installed but yes you
have the provisioning
that you can go for the installation of
those plugins and yes
those features will start embedded up
and integrated within your jenkins
so this is the reason this is the main
benefit which we get when we talk about
the jenkins implementation
so jenkins uh is you know one of the
best fit which is there for building a
ci cd pipeline
because of its flexibility uh open
source nature
plug-in capabilities the support for
plugins and it's quite easy to use and
it's very simple
straightforward gui which is there which
can definitely helps us you can you know
easily understand and go through the
jenkins and you can grab the
understanding
and as an end result you will be able to
have a very robust tool
which using which pretty much any kind
of source code
or any kind of programming language you
can implement ci cd
whether it's an android it's a not net
it's a
java it's a node.js all the languages
are having the support
for the jenkins so let's talk about the
ccd pipeline with the jenkins here
now to automate the entire development
process a ci cd pipeline is the ultimate
you know solution which we are looking
forward to build such a pipeline
jenkins is our best solution and best
fit which is available here
so there are pretty much six steps which
is involved when we look forward for any
kind of pipeline it's a generic pipeline
which we are looking forward
now it may have like any other steps
which is available there
probably some additional steps you're
doing like some other plugins you are
installing
but these are the basic steps which is
there like a minimum pipeline if you
want to design
these are the steps which is available
there now let's see the first one is
that
we have the uh required java jdk like a
jdk
to be available on the system now most
of the operating systems are already
available with the gre
like a java gre but the problem with gre
is that it's only for the build process
it will not be doing the compilation you
can run the artifacts you can run the
jar files you can
you know run the application run the
code base but the compilation requires
the java c
or the java jdk kit to be installed onto
the system
and that's the reason why for this one
we also require the jdk
and certain linux commands execution
understanding we need to have because we
are going to run some kind of steps
some installation steps and you know
process so that's pretty much required
now let's talk about how do ca cd
pipeline with jenkins now first of all
you have to download the jdk
and uh that is something which is
installed so after that you can go for
the
jenkins download now jenkins dot io
slash download is the website is our
official websites of jenkins
now the best part is that there you have
the support for different operating
systems and platforms
from there you can easily say that if
you want to go for a java uh package
like a war file
tucker ubuntu deviant centos fedora red
hat
windows open sushi uh freebsd ganto mac
operating system
in fact whatever the different kind of
artifacts or different environment or
different uh
application you want to download you
will be able to do that so that's a very
first thing to start up on
you download the generic java package
like a war file
then you have to execute it you have to
download that into a specific folder
structure let's say say that you have
you know created a folder called jenkins
now you have to go into that jenkins
folder with the help of cd command
and there you have to run the command
called java hyphen jar and the jenkins
dot bar there
so uh these are the executables uh
artifacts
so var files can be easily executable
jar files raw files can be easily
deployed so just because
with the java command you can run them
you don't require any kind of web
container or application container as
such
so here also you can see that we are
running the java command and it
runs the applications as such and once
that is done so you can open the
web browser and uh you can open like
localhost colony
t so jenkins uses atd port just like a
tomcat apache
so uh if you know once the deployment is
done
installation is done so you can just
open the localhost colony
now if you want to get uh the jenkins up
and running in the browser
probably you can you know go through the
uh public ip address also there
so you can put the public ipad is
calling 880 and that can also help you
to you know start
accessing the jenkins application now in
there you will be having an
option called create new jobs so you
need to click on that
now once the uh particular new job new
item new job that's a
different naming conventions which is
available there now all you're going to
do is that you're going to do like
you are proceeding with the creating the
pipeline job
so you will be having an option called
pipeline job over there just select that
and provide your
custom name what pipeline name or job
name you want to
refer or you want to process there now
once that is available
so what happens that it will be an easy
task for us to see that how exactly we
can go ahead and we can perform on that
part
so this can really help us to see that
how a pipeline job can be created and
you know
performed on this modifications as such
now when the pipeline is selected and we
can give a particular name that
this is the name which is available and
then we can say okay as such over there
now you can scroll down and find the
pipeline section so uh
there what happens that when you go over
there and say that okay
this is the way that how the pipelines
are managed and you know those kind of
things
so you will scroll down and find the
pipeline section and
go with that pipeline script now when
you select that option
there are different options which is
available like how you want to manage
these pipelines
now you are you know have the direct
access also
like if you want to directly create the
uh create a pipeline script you can do
that
if you feel that you want to manage like
you want to retrieve the
jenkins files also scored management
tool also can be used there so you can
work on that also
so like this there are so many a variety
of things which is available
like which you can use to work around
that how exactly the pipeline job can be
created so
either you can fetch it from the source
code management tool uh
like gate version or something like that
or you can directly put the pipeline
code as such over there
right now so next thing is that we can
configure and execute a pipeline
job with the direct script so uh we can
once the
pipeline is selected so you can put the
uh particular script like jenkins file
into your uh particular github link so
you
you may be having like already a github
link so that the where the jenkins file
is there so you can make use of that
now once you process the github link so
what we can do is that we can proceed
with that
and uh once the processing is done so
you can do the save and you know you can
keep the changes and
you know it will be picking up the
pipelines you know the pipeline script
is added up into the
github and you know you have already
specified that
uh let's just go ahead with this jenkins
file pipeline script from the github
repository and proceed further
now once that is done so what next you
can do is that you can go with the build
now process
you click on the bill now and once that
is done so what will happen
that you will be able to see that how
the build process will be done and how
the build will be performed over there
so these are pretty much a kind of a way
so you can click on the console output
you will get all the logs that is
happening in the inside that
whatever the pipeline steps are getting
executed all of them you will be able to
get or you will be able to you know get
on that part there
so these are the different steps which
is involved as such
and uh the sixth one is that you know uh
yes
whatever the uh particular uh when you
run the build now you will be able to
see that
source code will be uh you know will be
checked out and will be downloaded
before the build and you can proceed
with that part
now later on if you want to change the
url of this github you can configure the
job again
the existing job and you can change that
url github link url
whenever you require you can also clone
this uh job whenever you go ahead and
you work on that
and that's also kind of you know the
best part which is available as such
right and uh then you can have the
advanced
settings over there so in there you can
put like your github repository you can
say like okay
uh the github repository is there so i'm
just going to put this url
and you know with that what will happen
that the settings will be available
there
and the jenkins file will be downloaded
as such
and when you run the build now you will
be able to have a lot of steps like a
lot of
configurations going on so uh then
the checkout icm so we can have a
declaration like checkout sm which is
there so when the checkout sm is there
so it will check out a specific source
code
after that you go to the log and you
will be able to see that each and every
stage which is being built up and
executed as such okay
so now we are going to talk about a demo
here so on the pipeline
here so this is the jenkins portal now
you can see here that there is an option
called create a job
you can either click on the new item or
you can click on the new uh
create a job here now here i'm going to
say like a pipeline
uh then you know you can select the
pipeline uh
job type here now you have the freestyle
pipeline
github organization multiplicity branch
pipeline these are the different options
which is available there
but i'm going to continue with the
pipeline here as such so when i selected
the pipeline
and say okay so what will happen that i
will be able to see a configuration page
which is related to the pipeline
now here the very important part is that
you have all the uh general build
trigger uh you know options which is
similar to the
freestyle but the build step and the
post build step is completely removed
because of the pipeline introduction
now here you either have the option to
put the pipeline script all together
you can also have some particular
example for example let's talk about
some github
maven uh particular uh tool here so you
can see that
uh we have you know got some steps as
such over here and
you know it's pretty much running over
there now you run it it will
work smoothly it will check out some
source code but how we are going to
integrate like
the version the jenkins file into the
version control system because that's
the ideal approach we should be
following when we create a pipeline of a
ci cd
now i'm going to select a particular
pipeline from sem here
then go with the git here now in there
the jenkins file is the name of the file
of the pipeline script and i'm going to
put my
repository over here in this one now
this repository is of my gate
which is like having a maven built
pipeline which is available there
it's having some steps related to ci for
the build and deployments
and that's what we can follow as such
over here now in this one
the uh if it is a private repository
definitely you can add on your
credentials but this is a public
repository
a personal repository so i don't have to
put any kind of credentials
but you can always add the credentials
with the help of add here
and that can help you to you know set up
whatever the credentials
private repositories you want to
configure now once you save the
configuration here
now what it's going to do is that your
it's going to give you a particular page
related to build now
uh if you want to run if you want to
delete the pipeline if you want to
reconfigure the pipeline
all these different options are
available there so we are going to click
on the build now here
and when i do that immediately the
pipeline will be downloaded and will be
processed
now you may not be able to get the
complete stage view as of now because
it's still running
so yeah you can see that the checkout
code is done
then it's going on to the build okay
that's one of the steps which is there
now once the build will be done so it
will continue with the next steps with
the next for the steps there
so you can also go to the console
output log here like you can click on
this or you can click on the console
output
to check the complete log which is
happening there or
in fact you can also see the stage wise
logs also
because that is also very important when
you go for the complete logs
uh it may you know have a lot of steps
involved and you know a lot of logs will
be available there
but if you want to see a specific log of
a specific stage
that's where this comes into the picture
and as you can see that all the
different uh steps like test cases
executions
the scenar cube analysis the archive
artifacts deployment
and in fact the notification so all this
is a part of a complete pipeline
this whole pipeline is done here and you
know you get a kind of a stage view
it's success over here and the artifacts
is also available to download so you can
download this war file is a web
applications as such over here so this
is what our typical
pipeline looks like that how the
automation the complete automations
really looks like as such over here now
this is a very important aspect because
it really helps us to understand that
how the pipelines can be configured can
be done
and pretty much with the same steps you
will be able to automate any kind of
pipelines
as such so that was the demo to build a
simple pipeline as such with the jenkins
and uh pretty much in this one we
understood that how exactly the cicd
pipelines can be configured
and we can use them and we can get hold
on that part so that's it for this topic
i hope you got to understand now that
what is a cicd pipeline and how we can
automate it with the jenkins so thanks
everyone yeah bye-bye
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here